hey everybody it's me gary vaynerchuk
and this is overrated underrated in the
air edition
overrated or underrated what does gary
think
morel
pharrell
especially right this second
insanely underrated what a-list
celebrities have is they have ebbs and
flows they're unlike people that have
come up in the internet where they're
almost like constantly always on the
framework of people in the public eye in
the past was come on come off come on
come off
right now i think pharrell's creative
genius is so legit but my intuition
hence why i like doing this show is at
this second
not enough people actually realize to
what level so i'm gonna go not only
underrated i'm gonna give a unique
extremely underrated puerto rican so
we're flying from puerto rico right now
which is why i assume you're asking
i'm gonna go with properly rated here's
why i think it's underrated for the
masses because people people are still
thinking like that you know the
hurricanes and is it okay like you know
that's the mass thing and i think it's
overrated by the elite
wealthy coastal
kid that are all my friends and i love
them but they're like it's the best no
taxes but then like every day they're
like okay i have to be on the island for
another 84 days and they can't wait to
go to mainland and i think the
ideology's awesome
but there's been billionaires and
wealthy people for a long time and
there's a reason that even though they
want to move to places with tax havens
they don't uh zoom the internet has
changed some things private aviation
it's affordability in the scheme of that
wealth has changed some things uh but i
still think for that group it's
overrated i want to see where they're
living in 36 months
moon birds is underrated one of the most
successful most profound uh successes in
the nft space in the first year however
underrated because it's being driven by
kevin rose the actual poster child for
web 2 because of digg.com what i'm
referring to is on actual poster child
go right now and type in kevin rose
cover you'll see him on the cover of i
think business 2.0 or business week
anyway nonetheless he knows what he's
doing reminds me of me with consumer
intuition but he's he's maybe i'm a
little bit more marketing and more
intuition but he's definitely
85 percent of that and that other 15
he's more technically strong than i am
he's got more cto tech i expect a lot of
innovation from moon birds i think moon
that mover is very expensive right now
starting to settle in but i think um i
think uh long term that's one of the few
projects i would bet on
that's a tricky one i think kardashians
will be a rare overrated underrated and
properly rated such a basty ecosystem
uh
what a powerhouse lady crew chris jenner
is
you know one of the strongest
contemporary business strategists of the
last decade there's so much that comes
along with the rise of the kardashians
it's changed popular cultures perception
of beauty there's there's good and bad
when when
things come along with physical
appearance the business the work ethic
is through the roof the bond is real
which i you know as a as somebody who
adores their sister and brother
that matters a lot to me and i like i i
genuinely think this is a fun one to
answer i think it's all of the above i
think out of everything we've done in
this show
i think
many many many people overrate them
many many more in my opinion underrate
them and i think right now finally
enough people properly rate them and
understand
the supernova that it is the pros the
cons and the indifferences that come
along with anything with that level of
awareness
that's a good question nike nike's been
very interesting for me the last couple
of uh years because of
several things one i'm obsessed they
rest in peace the iconic genius that
virgil hablo is the off-white
collaboration completely changed this
the momentum of yeezy
in taking market share on under 25 year
old cool i'm also fascinated because
huge shout out to board a bob club and
yuga labs
so impressed with that execution in nft
land and i think about four days a lot
i'm like man is crocs which is actually
ironically back now
dominant 20 years ago three four year
run
disappeared off the face of the earth
and now back is it gonna be supreme
is it gonna be vape
is it going to be is it going to be nike
is it going to be ocean pacific but nike
out of all the brands
have stayed unbelievably consistent for
the last 30 years 25 years that is
profound and for that reason i'm going
to go with underrated
beet juice i think beet juice is
underrated
by the 80 percent and overrated by the
20 percent
elon's acquisition of twitter
is going to be
just a hair slightly
overrated meaning everyone gets excited
they're going crazy what's gonna happen
and everyone's kind of like gossipy dna
kicks it in moments like this i think
elon's gonna go and put in a team to
execute i think twitter is gonna
innovate more in the next 24 months than
it has in the last seven years what that
means predictions twitter could become a
monster player in ott
you know because i would what i'm good
at is like what would i do and i think
i'm good and i think elon is great and
so
uh i think i'm great too so ott
subscription um you know editing little
things like an editing button would come
in nice and handy you know i think
multimedia
uh the ott one's the big thing in the
back of the pocket you have that much
attention you could be subscription
twitter could be a major player in music
not just tick tock and spotify if it
wanted to uh animation nft land
i think you'll see a lot of innovation
of course the headlines will be like
does trump get unbanned and freedom has
been like there'll be all that emotion
but i think it'll settle in and it will
be about business execution
cruise ships are underrated i think that
i'm a huge fan
of micro
environments for moments in time i'm
obsessed with college
life
i hate college debt and you get out and
you're in big trouble that's been well
documented but i'm in love with college
first three-month ecosystem it is
fascinating to me that how many people
in the world have best friends
completely predicated on six weeks from
august to october when they're 18.
those those are four movement you know
you're out of your parents hat like it's
a micro culture coachella for a weekend
those four days a micro culture a five
day bachelor pet party it's a
microculture when you're stuck in
something for a little while and it
forms a community
cruise ships are so [ __ ] in the
middle of nowhere that that ship becomes
a family for a week you meet somebody
the first day like in the dining hall
and you just become homies there's
something about cruise ships that
creates micro communities micro cultures
for a quick period of time that i think
is profound and i like it underrated the
word from now the word profound right
now
is underrated by 7.9 billion people and
grossly overrated by one
the joke there that everyone's enjoying
right now is boy do i get excited about
a word and i lock in somewhere between
two and nine months usually if you're
paying attention the possums
are for sale what do you do well me
[ __ ] went crazy yesterday because one
of the co-founders of yugolab said that
he finally took a vacation because he's
gone hard for a year building board ape
and they've kudos i'm so happy for those
[ __ ] um but he said on vacation he
couldn't stop but thinking about the
utility for me bits
i'm super pumped because i have a
shitload of them i've been a fan of me
bits from day one i believe it's a real
project i think it's got a potential to
be under they're very expensive it's
hard to say something that is underrated
in such a high volatility market but if
i was to talk about list 25 ips that
could actually be playing in nft land in
a meaningful way in in five years me
bits would be on that list every day of
the week
i think reebok is underrated um i uh you
know it's under new management i'm i'm
very close and watching it i'm aware of
this but i've been surprised as i've
been like kind of watching under new
management you know new me somebody buys
it and and i like the people that bought
it so i'm watching it i'm like go go go
i'm rooting for you what that does in my
brain what i do for a living is i start
paying attention i'm like man a lot more
people like to kick the classic box that
i realized and that's before this new
team does all the smart [ __ ] underrated
coachella is
uh
something i've used as a proxy to talk
about the thing i most fear in the world
which is people being insecure and
unhappy and using thinking money will
make them happy because they need money
to do things and buy things to make them
happy which is not a sustainable play
you feel great for a weekend and then
it's tuesday after coachella coachella
is underrated as a business execution
and there's a brand talk about the
profound execution it has become an
iconic
weekend two weekends uh
for youth culture and that is
profound it is overrated for the tens of
thousands of people
that use it as
a
outlet of escapism for deep unhappiness
it is underrated for people that use it
as an outlet for escapism who are happy
and it's an opportunity to just reset
their energy
and so this all goes back to the same
game which is the luxuries in life
are incredibly binary they are either
incredibly dangerous on the flip side
all the great luxuries in the world for
the people that are content and happy
and feel great are incredible reset
escapisms
re-energizing moments that allow them to
go and execute on their enjoyment the
other 297 days a year
very interesting to think about
stunningly underrated uh especially by
millennials and boomers those two really
especially love to [ __ ] with gen z i
think gen x
and like we're kind of like more neutral
just because the way we ended up in age
boomers who gave birth to these [ __ ]
are like [ __ ] on them even though
they created all the things they [ __ ]
out they're so entitled you entitled
them you know eighth place trophies are
not gonna make people hungry to [ __ ]
win uh you know paying for your kid to
uber is not gonna make them work hard
and then millennials are like just
like pissed because like wait a minute
we're not the kids anymore i don't like
this so i'm empathetic to that group gen
z is incredibly creative
wildly uh awake
and not woke awake meaning they know
their options
everyone's like they're entitled no
they're not they want to make 57 000 a
year being a creator right like they're
so entitled they don't want to work at
[ __ ] walmart they'd rather garage
sale and flip and make twice as much
money they're lazy they're too
ideological no they don't want to work
in the accounting firm and getting an
accounting job because your family is
three generation accountants they don't
like accounting
they like music and so they're going to
go to la and live for seven years and
try to ground it out and then they're
gonna be 29 and be like okay i suck at
music now what they can do accounting
when they're 47.
[ __ ]
gen z's got it they need to stop talking
[ __ ] about every other generation gen z
talks so much [ __ ] about every other
generation
and they cry about generations talking
[ __ ] about them hypocrite gen z
that's our show
oh you got two the show's not over when
dustin's got two
i lost it
that one's tricky for me because i have
absolutely no knowledge
on batman since
the first three or four that happened in
the 80s and 90s 89 batman michael keaton
was like profound for our generation
because mainstream america and kids kids
didn't like completely lose their mind
for superman 89 batman every single six
to 16 year old male saw batman 89 in the
theater and it completely changed the
game i know there's so much emotion
about like ben affleck and robert like
and val kilmer like there's all the
emotion of the batman's i'm just so not
knowledgeable i'm gonna have to pass air
fryers air fryers i think air fryers are
really underrated i think they really
help people that can't cook and so for
that
underrated make sure you subscribe on
youtube hit some likes and most
importantly leave comments i read that
[ __ ] it's how i make this stuff better
that's for the show we'll see you next
time on overrated underrated
[Music]
honeydew is crazy underrated you think
so please add that to the list
we're going to overrate it under rain